The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So again, we go here
back up to the Examples, Intro,
Group Theory, start it up.
And then our first
example is group theory 1,
and it just goes through.
And basically, I came up
with a way in a spreadsheet
to define the functions
I was looking at,
and then start creating
combinations of them,
and then do very simple
tests on associativity
and [? distribution ?]
and all that stuff.
If you actually look
at the tests I do,
you might blanch
and be like, really?
You said that?
You declared that it
was fully associative?
It's not like I went in and did
formal proofs for everything.
I just did some very
quick numerical tests.
The semi-ring test actually
takes a while here,
as you can see.
And this will take
a minute here.
It appears to be hanging.
Oh, no, it's not.
Good.
We'll let it go through that.
In fact, while it does that,
we can look at-- basically,
these are inputs.
So basically, I
have my different--
what I call the key function.
I have union and
intersection, and then
I have the three possible
conditions-- v1 less than v2,
v1 equal to v2, v1
greater than v2,
and then essentially,
the different types
of operators, the results
that can occur from those.
And so this is a CSV
file, and we read it
in as [? associative ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
And so it looks
like a spreadsheet,
and I can actually have
columns named v1 less than v1.
Very powerful.
And in fact, I'm even
able to pass that column
into the Matlab Eval function
and have it actually execute
it, which is nice.
So I can actually have code
in my column or row names,
and then have
operations performed
based on that,
which is, I think,
a nice thing that you
can do when you allow
strings to be in your set.
Likewise, Matlab will formally
parse nan as nan and plus
minus inf as minus inf, and so
I can get all that functionality
out of there,
which is very nice.
And then it goes
through-- let's see here.
And these are just different
tests that we do on those.
STUDENT: Is nan a
special character?
PROFESSOR: Not a number.
Yeah, I kind of--
I use that as-- it
has a lot of the
properties of null
when you add it to
different functions.
So I'm using that for that,
and it works out pretty well.
So it's IEEE failure state modes
or whatever it's-- it appears
like that.
I can't remember if there is
a plus nan and negative nan
as well.
No.
It's just nan, yeah.
And then actually,
it goes through here,
and I think-- these are just
various ways of inputting--
these are different values,
different little spreadsheets
that you can make for
exploring these different types
of things.
And you can just write
them as little CSV files.
Very useful.
On Instruct here.
I do apologize for the
length of time it's taking.
I think having the QuickTime
video recording going
at the same time is
causing the poor computer
to sweat a little bit more
than it does normally.
It usually doesn't
take this long.
Outputs that it
comes up with-- it
basically writes all these out.
Look here.
This shows-- I ask it
to basically generate
all those 200 pairs.
So for each key and whatever,
it can go and generate
those for me.
So I create this little thing,
and it goes through and creates
this whole function, and
then writes that out as a CSV
itself, which is
very convenient.
Again, these are
things you can do.
I think this is the one
where we came up with all the
[? fields. ?] Oh, yeah.
It doesn't really fit there.
But you can see these are
the pairs that it found,
and it shows this is
the zero operator.
And again, this is all done
with D4M kinds of values
that it can store
different types of things.
This is how we made all the
tables that are in there.
Oh, it's writing out results.
That means it's done.
There we go.
And so the main
one I want to show
you is that we [? read in ?]
that function, func range,
and we permuted it.
And if we do display
full afunc, you
can see there is the full
combination of values
as we saw there.
So there's really
nothing here for you.
It's not I expect
you to go using
D4M to do group theory things.
That's not really the
point of these examples.
I did.
It's more just
showing that you can--
when you go into this
larger space, problems
that you might not solve
linear algebraically,
all the sudden,
it's like, oh yeah,
if I have strings and
other types of things,
it really opens up
the flexibility.
I thought that was very
neat that you could do this.
It just handled the
data very nicely
and without any real difficulty.
So with that, that's
the end of this lecture.
I don't know if there's
any final questions
before we proceed.
All right.
Very good.
And please, if you haven't
signed up on the sheet,
please do so.
Thank you very much.